你有沒有聽過一種說法，就是現在這個時代，做什麼都得快？像 AI 出現之後，好多公司都急著轉型，深怕慢一步就被淘汰。
嗯，這很常見啊，尤其在競爭激烈的市場，速度好像就是生存的關鍵。很多主管也會要求團隊動作要快，效率要高。這不是理所當然的嗎？
其實我一開始也不太看好，不過想了一下就想通了。最近有一篇文章就提出一個出乎意料的看法，它說在大家都追求速度的時候，反而「放慢腳步」才是能帶來長期優勢的策略。
怎麼說？這聽起來有點違反直覺耶。放慢腳步，不會錯失機會嗎？或者說，這模式撐得久嗎？成本划算嗎？
原文有提到一個例子，美國有差不多三分之一的人力資源經理，他們的公司因為 AI 裁員後，又把那些職位加回來了。你說這是不是就因為一開始太急，沒想清楚？
喔，這個很有意思。所以意思是，一開始因為急著跟風，結果決策錯誤，然後又要花更多時間和資源去修正？
對。這篇文章說，領導者常常因為「行動至上」的慣性，習慣快速解決問題。但當事情變得複雜，牽涉到人、流程、技術等多方面時，快速決策反而容易出錯。
這點我是信了，因為原文有提到具體數字，有將近三分之二的 CEO 說，他們的董事會催促 AI 轉型，這壓力會讓他們在不清楚實際需求前就開始行動。
是啊，有些決策好調整，但有些一旦做了，會產生長期的成本和複雜性。就像一個領導者分享，他以前也習慣快速下判斷，但後來發現，當他願意說「我還不確定」的時候，反而能收集更多資訊，考慮風險與機會，最終的決定會更好。
「我還不確定」這句話，對一個領導者來說，說出口其實不容易。這是不是會讓大家覺得他猶豫不決，不夠果斷？
可能會，但文章也提到一個重點：反射性思考是為了讓決策更精準，而不是拖延。那位領導者就是透過「反向思考」來幫助自己。
反向思考？怎麼做到的？
他會問：「要怎麼做才能保證失敗？」而不是只問「怎麼做才能成功？」從失敗的角度回推，反而能更清楚地看到需要避免的狀況。
這個做法很有意思。從避免失敗的角度去思考，的確能讓人更全面地考慮風險。但這需要很多時間吧？我們一般上班族，每天忙得要死，哪有空做這種深度思考？
其實不需要長時間。文章說，他最好的思考發生在開車、散步，甚至是一杯「思考濃縮咖啡」的時間。就是短暫地停下來，從繁忙的日常中抽離，換個角度看問題。
喔，所以不是要你關在小房間裡冥想好幾個小時，而是在日常瑣事中找到這些碎片時間？這點其實不容易做到，因為我們習慣了快速處理眼前的事。
嗯，原文中也提到，他們的領導團隊會一年三、四次，從日常工作中抽身，專注於「經營」公司，而不是只在公司「裡面」工作。這樣做，反而能讓他們突破舊有的慣性，處理好一些困擾好幾個月的問題。
所以對創業者或中小企業主管來說，是不是可以定期安排這種「策略性放空」時間？哪怕只是每週預留一小時，把手邊的緊急事放下來，思考一下更大的方向？
我覺得可以試試看。就像我們台灣很多小店，常常為了追求快速翻桌率、快速出餐，結果忽略了服務品質或餐點的細節。如果能偶爾停下來，想想如何把單一產品做到最好，是不是反而能建立更深厚的品牌價值？
嗯，說到小店，如果我開一家咖啡店，可能一開始會很想多賣一點，但如果我能放慢速度，把每一杯咖啡的品質都顧好，讓客人感覺到用心，長期下來也許更能留住客人。
對啊。那對一般上班族來說，我們也可以把這個概念帶入工作和生活。比如面對一個複雜的任務，與其馬上動手，不如先花個十分鐘，整理一下思緒，想想最核心的問題在哪裡。
或是說，當我們被各種資訊轟炸的時候，不是急著消化所有東西，而是偶爾停下來，問問自己：「這件事真的重要嗎？還是只是看起來很緊急？」
好像也提醒了我們，在追求效率和速度的同時，有時候，刻意的慢，反而才是快。